so here's a question what makes someone
worthy of wielding Thor's hammer is it
something
simple as being a good person or is
there more to it than that
what we're going to do in this video is
we're going to answer that question well
what we're also going to do is we're
going to answer the question of if
someone is unworthy to wield Thor's
hammer can they still pick it up and
then we're going to do is we're going to
round out this discussion by trying to
answer the question why was the vision
able to wield Thor's hammer and Avengers
2 age of Ultron so to the first question
what makes someone worthy well to answer
this question we have to refer to Thor
vol 1 issues number 158 and 159 then
what this does is it gives us the reason
as to why Thor was cast out of Asgard
and what caused him to lose the ability
to lift his hammer in the first place
now what odin tells us in this story is
that Thor had all the makings of an
Asgardian King Thor was brave in the
face of battle even if it meant that he
might die Thor demonstrated honor
towards what he called friends or those
individuals he referred to as friends
fighting alongside them until the very
end of the battle no matter how that
battle may end and Thor was normal in
the sense that he always put the lives
of others above his own but the one
quality that Thor lacked was humility
that his great deeds had basically led
him to believe that he was the greatest
in all of Asgard and so he was cast out
until a time came when he became humble
now using this reasoning of Odin what we
basically get is this kind of checklist
of what makes a person worthy to wield a
hammer the first is that a person must
be brave in the face of battle even if
Doom is imminent even if they know for a
fact that they're going to die a person
must also understand that it's not
enough to simply just save lives the
intention has to be selfless they have
to put the lives of others above their
own because it's what they truly want to
do not because it's what they think they
should do and finally a person has to be
humble in this and so they have to
realize that they may not be capable of
lifting the hammer of Thor and that they
may be brave enough to try it anyway but
that such power would most likely be
beyond them and so what we find here is
that if you guys recall my video on the
top six characters at I chose and
terms of all the people who were able to
lift Thor's hammer that those top six
characters along with all the ones we
didn't mention had elements they
basically had all these different
attributes that came together in any one
circumstance now they don't have to have
these elements all the time they don't
have to be this kind of person 100% of
the time it could just be that at the
right time in the right battle all these
elements combine to a place where they
can suddenly lift Thor's hammer and as
soon as they stop being that kind of
person they lose the ability to wield a
hammer it's really just kind of
contextual here this is the most likely
circumstance that we see when someone's
able to pick the hammer up but they
can't do it anymore this is basically
what's happening here is they suddenly
become this kind of person in the heat
of battle and then once the battle is
over they revert back to their normal
self now from here the question becomes
if someone is unworthy what happens if
they try to lift the hammer and is there
a way for an unworthy person to actually
lift the hammer anyway well this is
actually a really interesting question
because up until 2010 we never had an
answer we didn't know why those who try
to lift the hammer failed except to say
that it had something to do with Odin's
enchantment that was really all we got
we weren't really given an explanation
but all this changed in 2010 with JEP
Lowe Jeff Labs run on general
Thunderbolt Ross as the Red Hulk and
what Jeff lobe wanting to do was he
wanted to introduce a scenario where Red
Hulk was able to defeat Thor using
Thor's hammer
but as editor Tom Brevoort told us or I
guess mentioned in an interview this was
not going to happen as long as the two
were fighting on the planet Earth and
the reason was because one of the most
important aspects of Thor's continuity
and the power of the hammer of Thor is
that only the worthy can lift it if Jeff
lobe were to somehow adjust this or what
to say that an unworthy person can lift
it even if you know they're standing or
they're fighting on the planet Earth it
would destroy the value of the
enchantment that Odin had put on the
hammer and so what Jeff lobe did is he
gave us a loophole what happens is that
while Red Hulk and Thor are fighting
they eventually take to space and
oneness of happening here is that while
they're fighting in space that Red Hulk
takes the hammer of Thor away from Thor
and what he says is that in a weightless
environment that is to say were gravity
doesn't apply that there is no
enchantment the enchantment that was put
on the hammer by Odin doesn't apply here
and so what this tells us is that the
enchantment that was put on the hammer
by Odin works directly with gravity
itself meaning that the harder a person
pulls the hammer the heart of the
gravitational pull on the hammer
effectively making it infinitely heavy
now to the final question why was the
vision able to lift Thor's hammer in the
age of Ultron well this actually comes
the form of two possibilities the first
possibility is that the vision was
simply just worthy that for whatever
reason his character or his mind existed
in such a place that he was a worthy
person but this is actually this is most
likely unlikely the most likely
explanation comes in the form of
she-hulk volume 2 issue number 14 and
2007 what model did was they basically
brought back a long-standing but really
minor character named awesome Andy and
awesome Andy was an Android that could
quite literally mimic the powers of
other people whenever he touched them
now while awesome Andy was fighting Thor
he wasn't necessarily able to mimic the
power of force ability to lift his
hammer but what Marvel told us is that
the enchantment that Odin had put on the
hammer only applies to living beings it
only applies to sentient beings that is
to say beings who are flesh and blood
so aliens different things like that but
it does not apply to robots and so what
this basically means is that whenever a
robot tries to lift the hammer that
because the robot cannot be either good
or evil it's simply just cancelling out
the worthiness factor when a robot can
lift a hammer with no real problem but
this again presents other questions it
presents other continuity errors for
example and the continuity of beta ray
bill a character we had discussed who
was a robot if he was a cyborg and he
was able to lift the hammer then why was
it Odin had simply said that beta ray
bill was able to lift the hammer because
he was worthy this is the kind of thing
that we don't know these are the kind of
answers that we simply just don't have
in the comics this is the kind of
continuity issues that you run into in
Marvel and so whether or not the vision
was basically able to lift the handle
because he was worthy or because he was
an Android is a question that we may not
get the answer to Kevin Figgy in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe may never tell
us
but hopefully somewhere along the line
they will hopefully we'll get some
measure resolution in terms of why this
happened with that being said I'm going
to go ahead and bring this video to an
end I hope you guys enjoyed it if you
did let me know and I will catch you
guys
you